[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
بعد اعترافه بسيطره الروس على بخمه يتراجع
ويؤكد وجود قوته في المدينه
دوري الان هو اني امثل المملكه في هذه
المهمه العلميه علامات رحله اي اكس 2 وتعد
هذه البعثات الفضائيه هي احدى ثمار هذه
الرؤيه ترقب سعوديه عربيه عالميه لاطلاق
مهمه السعوديه الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه
بعد ساعات
وان شاء الله تبارك الله على تجاوبكم
وشكرا على موقفكم هذا مع الترحيب الدولي
بالهدنه الجديده في السودان الجيش يستبعد
منها المسائل السياسيه
[موسيقى]
واقليميه لاقتحام احد المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين لباحه الاقصى للمره الثانيه
اذا مشاهدينا معركه باخموت التي وصفت
بمفرمه اللحم طالت اكثر من اي معركه اخرى
خلال الحرب في اوكرانيا معركه باخموت
وخلال ثمانيه اشهر كلفت كلا من روسيا
وايضا اوكرانيا العديد من الارواح ورغم
هذه المده الطويله لم يتم تحديد المنتصر
وتضارب التصريحات بشان هويه المسيطر فوسط
نفي اوكراني اعلن مؤسس مجموعه فانار
الروسيه
السيطره الكامله على باخمه شرقي اوكرانيا
قال ان قوته ستبدا مغادره المدينه الخميس
المقبل وستسلمها للجيش الروسي الجيش
الاوكراني من جانبه رد قائلا ان قوته لا
تزال صامده في باخمت فقد اكدت نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني حنا مليار في منشور عبر
تيليجرام اكدت ان القوات الاوكرانيه لا
تزال تحتفظ بالدفاع طول ضواحي المدينه
الصناعيه المسؤوله الاوكرانيه اضافت ان
قوات بلادها حتى على بعض المنشات الصناعيه
والبنى التحتيه في المنطقه بالاضافه الى
القطاع الخاص جدير بالذكر ان تقع على بعد
حوالي عشرين كيلو متر من منطقه لوغانس
وكانت هدفا لموسكو وذلك منذ شهور لذا فان
الاستيلاء عليها سيمثل نجاحا طالا انتظاره
وسيحقق بعض المكاسب الاستراتيجيه في حين
ستعاني اوكرانيا من هزيمه سياسيه
ومعنويه بحسب خبراء طبعا هذا وتراجع ايضا
الرئيس الاوكراني عن الاعتراف بخساره
بخموت مؤكدا ان قوتي لا تزال موجوده في
المدينه انه لا يمكن اعتبار المدينه تحت
السيطره الروسيه زيلينسكي كان قال في وقت
سابق ضمنا بان قواته فقدت السيطره على
المدينه دعونا نتابع
اعتقد اننا فقدنا سيطره على مدينه لكن
عليكم ان تفهموا انها تحولت الى لا شيء
الروس دمروها بالكامل لا يوجد فيها بناء
الامر ماساوي اليوم بامكاننا القول ان
باخمت فقط في قلوبنا لا يوجد شيء هناك الا
الدمار والكثير من القتل الروس الذين اتوا
الينا الاوكرانيون الذين دافعوا عن بخموت
قاموا بعمل قوي وبالطبع نحن نقدرهم على
جهودهم رائعه
هذا بالنسبه لزنسكي بالمقابل الرئيس
الروسي بلاديمير بوتنهنئه قوات فاغنر
والجيش الروسي بعد اعلان سيطرتهم على
مدينه
وفي بيان قال ان الرئيس الروسي اصدر
توجيهاته برفع اسماء ابطال العمليه
المتميزين لتقليدهم اوسمات الشرف التي
استحقوها
المزيد معنا من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد اهلا بك عبد الجواد اذا نفي
اوكرانيا كامل بان تكون موسكو قد سيطرت
على باخموت هل من تاكيدات او رد بالمقابل
روسي على هذه التصريحات والنفي تحديدا
كامل سيطرتها على مدينه بخمه هذا الاعلان
جاء على لسان
وعلى لسان وزاره الدفاع وعلى لسان
الخارجيه الروسيه التي تحدثت صباح اليوم
ونشرت مقاما بنشره
بالسيطره على بخمه ايضا مجلس الامن الروسي
يتحدث على لسانه
تحت السيطره طبعا في اخر الاخبار ميسونه
من الان وتحدث عن انه في اراضي مدينه
فخموت حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد اي جندي
اوكرانيا حسب روايته باعتبار معللا هذا
الشيء بانه لا يوجد من يمكن اخذهم في
الاثر من القوات الاوكرانيه تحدث طبعا عن
وجود عدد كبير من الجثث المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين وان الرئيس هو ديمر زيلينسكي
ليس على علم بشكل كامل
فيما يحدث في مدينه
القضيه كبيره طبعا قضيه
وذكرنا هذا الموضوع بس عندي نقطه فيما
يتعلق بتصريحات بروجيجين الذي قال فيها
بانه سيتم تسليم باخمه للقوات الروسيه
المتواجده هناك او انه في تحرك الان وهل
يمكن القول انه يوم الخميس هو اليوم
الشاهد اذا مصحه تعبير على من يسيطر على
ماذا
حتى تنشر اليوم العديد من مقاطع الفيديو
من رفع للعالم الروسي في بعض المناطق من
رفع رايه مجموعه فوق اعلى نقطه في
عبد الجواد طالت الحرب على باقمت ولكن اذا
مصحت التصريحات
الروسيه انه الوقت قد حان للسيطره عليها
او استلامها بصوره عامه ما هي الخطوه ما
بعدها وخاصه في ظل تصريحات السبع فيما
يتعلق بدعم اوكرانيا
في اعلان او لا
طبعا ميسور نعم يعني من الداخل الروسي
يمكن الحديث عن نقطه مهمه تحدث عنها بانه
بعد تسليم مدينه ضخمه القوات الروسيه
ستخرج قوات فاجنر للتعافي نوعا ما وليعاده
التدريب والتهيئه هذا المصطلح طبعا اعاده
التدريب والتهيئه والتجهيز يعني وضع من
جديد علامه استفهام جديده امام الكثير من
متابعين مجموعه بانه هل ستوبل مهمات جديده
نحو الامام يعني يدور الحديث معنى
وغيرها من المدن التي تعقب مدينه باخمس
نحو الغرب لكن طبعا ضخمه تعتبر نقطه
استراتيجيه ميسون كل الاقاويل التي تدور
عن ان هذه المدينه ليس لها اهميه وانما هي
عباره عن كسر معركه لاحد الاطراف هذا
الشيء غير صحيح حسب قراءه الخبراء
العسكريين في البلاد هي الطريق العسكري
الاول للدعم لكافه الجيوش وخاصه الجيش
الاوكراني من الجهه الغ ربيه لذلك طبعا
هذه الايام الخمسه القادمه او اصبحت
الاربع القادمه هي حاسمه بشكل كبير ستظهر
فيها الكثير من التفاصيل ومقاطع الفيديو
تنتشر كالنار في الهشيم في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وعلى تيليجرام بالتحديد مكان
تواجد يعني القنوات التي تقوم بنقل الصراع
الاوكراني بشكل كبير
شكرا جزيلا لك
ايضا المحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيد اندريه
بدايه قراءتك لحرب التصريحات هذه ما بين
الطرفين الى اي حد هي مفيده بالفعل بعيدا
عن ما يحدث على الارض والميدان
انه شيء طبيعي
الكامل
بسبب روسيا نجحت في ذلك متزامنا مع القمه
فتصوري لو اعترف
بذلك في وسط هذه القيمه مع الشركه الاخرين
في هذه القمه بطبيعه الحال هي ستكون ضربه
قويه ضد درب سياسيه درب الاعلاميه
الحل ربما نحن
نرى اعتراف بذلك بعد وصول الى الوراء الى
اسمح لي انت تقول بانه ربما يكون قد قام
او اطلق مثل هذه التصريحات
ربما لارضاء الغرب اذا مصحه تعبير
لاستكمال دعمه يبدو انه الغرب غير معني
بما يحدث على الارض والدعم مستمر
دعم مستمر ولكن في نهايه المطاف قد تكون
هناك تساؤلات مع مصلحه في تقديم هذا دعم
العسكري
توجد هناك خسائر على الارض يعني لا توجد
هناك نجاحات بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه
طبعا
الضخمه يمكن ان نسميه كنجاح تكتيكي بنسبه
بسبب انا في نهايه المطاف الكل حاليا
ينتظر ما يصابر بالهجوم المضاد من قبل من
قبل اوكرانيا ولكن في حل فاشل هذا الهجوم
المضافه
كما نقول ستكون هناك تساؤلات حول جدوى
استمرار هذه للمساعدات العسكريه اسمرار
هذه المصادر العسكريه هذا اذا لم يثبت بان
الاوكران لا زالوا يتواجدون في بخموت ماذا
لو ثبت يوم الخميس القادم انه الروس غير
متواجدين وغير قادر الجيش على السيطره على
باخموت
[موسيقى]
اكثر من مره كل دعم تقول في روسيا انه
المواجهه مع الغرب تغيرت الان
بصراحه نحن دائما نسمع هذه الدجل
الاعلاميه اولا حول هذه ثم حول المنظومات
باتري الخليله حول اف 16
16 ولكن الصوره اللي هي البسيطه يعني لا
يوجد خيار اخرا الا استمرار العمليه
العسكريه تحرير المدن والقرى والبلدات
ولما هنالك اي طبعا بصراحه لا يمكن ان
تؤدي ذلك الى تغيير الاستراتيجيه الروسيه
هل يتم تسليم هذه الطائرات لاوكرانيا طبعا
روسيا ستقوم باسقاطها كما قامت روسيا
بتدمير منظومات كما قامت مؤخرا
بفرض الاضرار على منظومه باتري هنالك اي
يعني طبعا هذه الاستمرار هذه المصادات لا
تؤدي الى تغيير النوايا الاستراتيجيه من
موسكو المحل الاساسي اندريه شكرا جزيلا لك
رغم اعلان قوات فاجنر والدفاع الروسيه
السيطره الكامله على مدينه باقمت الا ان
معارك مستعره ما زالت يخوضها الجيش الروسي
امام القوات الاوكرانيه وذلك في مدن عده
شمالا وغرب المقاطعه من اهمها مدينه التي
يتحصن الاوكرانيون بقنادق اعدوا لها منذ
حوالي التسع سنوات كاميرا العربيه وصلت
اطراف هذه المدينه ونقلت لنا الصوره وايضا
الاوضاع دعونا نتابع
مدينه افديفكا التي تشهد ايضا معارك طاحنه
وساخنه تحاول القوات الروسيه تطويق
المدينه او توسيع الطوق على المدينه في
ذات الوقت الذي يحاول الجيش الروسي فيه
اقتحام المدينه من عده جوانب مغطاه
بالضربات المدفعيه ورجيمات الصواريخ كما
ان المقاتلات الروسيه تقصف باستمرار
وبقنابل ذكيه مواقع الجيش الاوكراني داخل
المدينه
اذا توقف الغرب عن ارسال الاسلحه الاست
راتيجيه فذلك الامر تعجل بانتصارنا اما مع
استمرار الدعم المادي وبالسلاح الحديث
والمتطور فتقدمنا سيكون بطيئا نوعا ما
وتشهد بلده برلمايسكا الواقعه من الناحيه
الجنوبيه والغربيه ما بين مدينتيكا
ومارينكا معارك ضاريه حتى الان ذلك بعد ان
سيطر الجيش الروسي في معارك محتدمه منذ
اول العام الماضي وحتى الان على نصفي
القريه
بخصوص الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني استطيع
القول بان الجيش الاوكراني حاول مرارا
العوده وتنفيذه هجمات ضدنا وقد تمكن من
ايقافهم ونحن ما زلنا ننتظر استمرار
هجومهم لكنها دعايه غربيه بالعموم
لارهابنا هذا المكان هو سكن عسكريه للجنود
الروس في المناطق المتاخمه لمدينه
افديفيكا المحتدمه بالمعارك نرى اثار
الدمار الذي خلفته قذيفه سقطت بجانب هذا
الش هنا لم يسفر هذا القصف عن ضحايا ولا
اصابات لكن من الواضح ان المنطقه تشهد
معارك ضاريه وقسم متبادل ما بين الطرفين
الروسي والاوكرانيا
وعلى هذا الحال تستمر المعارك في مدينه
اقتحام روسي وصمود اوكراني وهجوم مضاد دون
منتصر حتى الان على الاقل لقناتي العربيه
والحدث رائد الاغبر اطراف افديفيكا
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
دوري الان هو اني مثل المملكه في هذه
المهمه العلميه علامات رحله وتعد هذه
البعثات الفضائيه هي احدى ثمار هذه الرؤيه
ترقب سعوديه عربيه عالميه الانطلاق مهمه
السعوديه الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه بعد
ساعات
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اعلنت
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
بيان مشترك كان طرفي الصراع في السودان
الجيش طبعا السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
وقع على اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار لمده سبعه
ايام جاء في البيان المشترك ان وقف اطلاق
النار سيدخل حيز التنفيذ بعد 48 ساعه من
التوقيع ويمكن تمديده بموافقه الطرفين
البيان اضاف ان الجانبين اتفقا على ايصال
وتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه واستعاده
الخدمات الاساسيه بالاضافه الى سحب القوات
من المستشفيات والمرافق العامه الاساسيه
كما اتفقت طرفان على تسهيل المرور الامن
لمقدمي لمساعدات الانسانيه مما يسمح بتدفق
المساعدات دون عوائق من موانئ الدخول الى
السكان المحتاجين
حرص المملكه العربيه السعوديه وخادم
الحرمين الشفين والعهد على السودان وعلى
استقرار السودان وعلى امن السودان
ونسال الله ان شاء الله ان يرفع هذه الغمه
على السودان وعن اهلها ان شاء الله
والحقيقه شاكرين على موقفكم هذا اليوم
وعلى تعاونكم في الوصول الى هذا الاتفاق
واهل السودان منتظرين هذا وهذا ان شاء
الله في خير كثير يعني تعرفون انه الدم
هذا غالي ودم السوداني غالي وانتم
تاخذونها اكثر يعني اكثر من اي احد فان
شاء الله هذا الاتفاق سيكون بصيص امل لاهل
السودان بالذات اهل الخرطوم في انه يعني
يستطيعون ان يعالجون امورهم الانسانيه في
هذه الايام وان شاء الله تمتد الى اكثر
وان شاء الله تكون خطوه في الطريق الصحيح
فبارك الله فيكم وشكرا لكم على تجاوبكم
وشكرا على موقفكم هذا وان شاء الله يعني
ما نرى من بعد هذا الا كل الخير للسودان
واهل السودان ان شاء الله
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه في تغريده له عبر
تويتر قال ان الوقت قد حان لاسكات المدافع
والسماح بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه من دون
عوائق الناشده الجانبين التمسك بهذا
الاتفاق مشيرا الى ان انظار العالم تراقب
المزيد معنا من ام درمان الصحفي في مكتب
العربيه في السودان شهدي نادر اهلا بك
استاذ شهدي اسمح لي ان ابدا باخر التطورات
الميدانيه هل كان هناك انعكاس
للاعلان عن هذه الهدنه على الميدان وباي
طريقه
مرحب على الرغم من بدايه هذا اليوم بهدوء
كبير في جميع انحاء مدينه ام درمان
باستثناء طلعات خفيفه لسلاح الجو السوداني
في مناطق جنوبهم درمان الان يتجدد
التحليق طيران سلاح الجو السوداني تم قصف
تمركز لقوات الدعم السريع في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري قبل دقائق قليله تدوي حتى
هذه اللحظه اصوات المضادات الارضيه
باستثناء وكذلك شهد صباح اليوم اشتباكات
في محيط القصر الرئاسي بحسب ما علمنا صباح
هذا اليوم ولكنها اشتباكات كانت خفيفه
باستثناء ذلك اليوم يمضي هادئا بدا
الطيران الطيران سلاح الجو في التحليق
بشكل مكثف منذ حوالي ساعه سبقه في ذلك
تحليق لبعض طائرات الاستطلاع ولكن على
العموم اليوم قامت بشكل كبير اصوات الدول
الاسلحه الثقيله التي كنا نسمعها خلال
الايام الماضيه على الرغم من ان هناك اكثر
من 24 ساعه متبقيه لتدخل الهدنه حيزل حيزل
حيز التنفيذ نعم وكان في حديث على قصه ان
تكون هناك
رقابه دوليه ربما عن ماذا نتحدث هنا هل من
توضيح
نعم كما تعلمين منذ منذ الهدنه الاولى هذه
الهدنه هي تكاد تكون الهدنه التاسعه في
ظرف سته اسابيحي عمر الحرب التي اندلعت
فيها الخامس عشر من ابريل هذه الهدنه
الاولى التي يكون فيها نص حول وجود اليه
للمراقبه لا نعلم ان كانت هذه الاليه
ستكون عبر نشر نقاط من المنظمات والمعنيين
بامر امر المراقبه وكذلك من الطرفين
عبر الاقمار الاصطناعيه ولكن يوم غد هي
يفترض ان ان تنزل خلال الهدن السابقه كانت
الهدن يتم خرقها قبل ان تبدا هذه المهم
فيها انها اول هدنه يتم اقرار في هذه
الاسماء يعني يقوم سلاح الجوبي قص في موقع
شرقي عن مدينه ام درمان هناك اصوات لو كنت
تستمعين اليها
نعم هذه هي هذه هي الهدنه الاولى التي
يكون فيها اقرار بتشكيل اليه للرقابه
مشكله من الطرفين طبعا والامم ترحب بهذا
الاعلان كما نشاهد نعم سيد شهدي على
الهواء مباشره في العواجل الان الامم
المتحده ترحب بالاعلان عن وقف مؤقت لاطلاق
النار في السودان وبهذا الاطار طبعا هناك
دعوات لادخال المساعدات حجم المساعدات
التي تدخل طبيعتها الان وماذا نتوقع ايضا
نعم فيما يلي مساله مساله المساعدات كما
تعلمين منذ الاسبوع الاول وصلت كثير جدا
من
المساعدات من عده الدول المركز الملك
سلمان اللجنه الدوليه لصليبا للصليب
الاحمر الهلال الاحمر عده الدول كان اخرها
طائر هنديه قبل يومين حطت في مطار
بورسودان وصلت بها مساعدات هذه المساعدات
تصل حتى ولايه الجزيره التي تم اختيارها
لتكون المركز لتوزيع المساعدات الخرطوم
طرقها غير امنه الاشتباكات في في كل مكان
كانت تعيق ايصال هذه هذه المساعدات الى
داخلها والى المناطق المتضرره قبل قليل
كنا نتحدث معه عدد من المسؤولين في وزاره
الصحه ولايه الخرطوم كما تعلمين ان 24
مستشفى احتلتها قوات الدعم السريعه وطالها
القصف 5 مؤسسات حيويه ايضا هي خارج خارج
الخدمه احداها مخزن
الطبيه المركزي هو اكبر مستودع لتخزين
الادويه والمعينات الاطيبيه في البلاد
المفروض عليه حظر من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع المسؤوليه الصحه يقولون بان فتره
السبع ايام من شانها اذا ما توفر عامل
الامر للكوادر الطبيه فتح مسارات امنه في
تحسين في تحسين الخدمات الطبيه المقدمه في
المستشفيات التي تعمل اما التي طالها
القصف والتخريب فموكد انها ستحتاج الى وقت
اطول من ذلك حتى حتى تدخل حتى تتمكن من
العوده الى اعادتها الى الخدمه هذا في في
جاني في جانب اخر كذلك شددوا على اهميه
نعم طيب على كل تحسين خدمات المياه
والكهرباء والوقود لان المستشفيات
صحيح شكرا من درمان الصحفي في مكتب
العربيه في السودان شهدي نادر شكرا جزيلا
لك
هذا ورحبت قوى الحريه والتغيير في السودان
باتفاق الهدنه دعت في بيان الى الالتزام
الكامل باعلان مبادئ جده وباتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار قصير الامد وايضا طبعا
الترتيبات الانسانيه اعربت عن الامل بان
يشكل هذا الاتفاق خطوه في طريق وقف الحرب
من جانبه وصف رئيس حزب المؤتمر السوداني
عمر القير توقيع اتفاق الهدنه الانسانيه
بخطوه ايجابيه اخرى في معالجه الكارثه
الانسانيه بالسودان
وقد اكد الجيش السوداني ان اتفاق الهدنه
لمده اسبوع الذي جرى التوافق عليه مع قوات
الدعم السريع خلال محادثات جده ينحصر فقط
على الجوانب العسكريه والفنيه ولا يتضمن
المسائل السياسيه الجيش السوداني دعا في
بيان قوات الدعم السريع الى الالتزام
بالهدنه التي تم التوافق عليها في جده
لتسهيل ايصال وتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه
واستعاده الخدمات وسحب القوات من
المستشفيات والمرافق العامه الاساسيه
وتسهيل المرور الامن لمقدمي المساعدات
الانسانيه والسلع
المزيد معنا من القاهره رئيس تحرير صحيفه
التيار السودانيه عثمان مرجاني اهلا بك
استاذ عثمان بدايه قراءتك لهذه الهدنه
وكيف يمكن لها ان تختلف عن سابقاتها
هي خطوه للامام بكل تاكيد لان الاستمرار
المباحثات المفاوضات في جده لفتره طويله
دون ان يكونوا منها
عايد مشهود امام الجميع وتوقيع اتفاقيات
حتى ولو كانت فيها تقدم بسيط عن اتفاقيه
السابقه قد قد يمنح الاحساس بان هناك نوع
من الاستعصاء وربما قد يؤدي الى انهيار
المباحثات الان هذه الاتفاقيه فيها بعض
الاوجه التي تختلف عن الهدن السابقه على
سبيل المثال وجود الرقابه اليه الرقابه
رغم انها حتى الان اليه غير معروفه بصوره
دقيقه وحتى ولو كانت تتوفر هذه الاليه على
الارض من مراقبين سيكون من الصعوبه بمكان
ان يكون هناك رقابه حقيقيه على كل المواقع
لكن في كل الاحوال مجرد الاعتماد الان
وهذه النقطه مهمه جدا والتعويل على اراده
الطرفين في السلام هو خطوه الى الامام لان
هذه الاتفاقيه تعتمد اعتماد كلي على قدره
بين اولا في التحكم على القوات وفي اراده
الطرفين فعلا الوصول الى هدنه انسانيه
تسمح للمواطن السوداني للوصول للخدم
وسنتحدث عن هاتين النقطتين ولكن كونك ذكرت
الاليه ومهم جدا الحديث عنها وذكرت
الصعوبات ولكن اذا ما حاولنا ان نقرا في
طياتها ما هو الممكن بهذا الاطار نحن
نتحدث عن رقابه اقليميه ودوليه ومن هي
الاطراف التي يمكن ان يكون لها قدره على
الرقابه على الارض
طبعا هناك امكانيه وهناك تجارب يعني حتى
في السودان كانت هناك تجارب في دارفور في
تجارب في جنوب السودان سابقا كانت هناك
اليه للرقابه ولكن
الاليه التي كانت متوفر في هذه المناطق
كانت هي قوات حفظ السلام بمعنى ان هناك
قوات مسلحه دائما تحت شعار اما الامم
المتحده الافريقي تحت رايه هذه المنظمات
الدوليه وكانت تفرض السلام على الطرفين
بمعنى انها موجوده على الارض بسلاحها الان
اليه الرقابه مختلفه هي مجرد مراقبين
ينظرون الى الطرفين ويدونون ويرصدون اي
خروقات لكن دون ان يكون لهم القدره على
التعاطي والتعامل المباشره وحتى توفير
الحمايه المدنيين اذا كان هناك خروقات من
الطرفين هي ربما تكون اليه رقابه ربما
رمزيه يعني ليست سودانيه سيد عثمان بمعنى
اخر اسمح لي يعني انا بدي افهم لانه معظم
السفارات سحبت
ممثليها على الارض نحن نتحدث عن ايادي
سودانيه ستمثل جهات معينه ام ماذا برايك
من خلال القراءه والتجارب
لا هو هي سيكون هناك خبراء او عسكريون من
بعض الدول خاصه الدولتين في هذه المفاوضات
سيرصد هذه الاجراءات على الارض خبراء
عسكريون ومعهم من الجانبين من الجانب
الجيش السوداني ايضا ممثلون لجيش السوداني
في الرقابه وممثلون للقوات الدعم السريه
في الرقابه فهي اذا
الارض سيد عثمان لانه صار في بعض الخروقات
نعم يعني هي صحيحه هذه الاسئله التي
تتفضلين بها هي واقعه وشخصه لكن اكثر من
ذلك اين سيراقبون هذه نقطه يعني انا ساقول
يعني من واقع وجود مثلا عندما كنت موجودا
في داخل العاصمه السودانيه سافترض فرضا
واحدا مثلا الوصول الى مستشفى ام درمان
وهو مستشفى مهم جدا يخدم قطاع كبير جدا
عده مئات من الالاف من المواطنين هذا
المستشفى الوصول اليه هناك طريق واحد يمكن
ان يوصل اليه بصوره طريق رئيسي كيف يمكن
الرقابه والتاكد ان لا يكون هناك اي عوائق
في الوصول الى هذا المستشفى حتى ولو وصلت
الادويه نفترض ان الادويه وصلت والكوادر
الطبيه وصلت كيف يصل المريض الى هذا
المستشفى اذا لم تكن هناك رقابه محدده
بممرات امنه محدده بصوره دقيقه سيكون من
الصعوبه بمكان افتراض ان تكون هناك رقابه
على كامل ولايه الخرطوم التي بها عمليات
في المكان
هذه هذه الخطه وصلت النقطه بس خوفا من
ماذا لانه اذا كان في وقت لاطلاق النار
الا اذا كان هناك نوع من التخوف ان لا
تستطيع القيادات السيطره على العناصر
وذكرت انت نقطه مهمه في البدايه بهذا
الاطار هل هناك بالفعل خوف من هذه النقطه
تحديدا
هناك خوف كبير بل اعتقد ان هذه هي النقطه
الرئيسيه ساعطيك مثال بسيط هناك بيانات
صدرت من وزاره الخارجيه امس يعني وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه تتحدث عن اعتداء على
بعض السفارات من ضمنها السفاره السعوديه
نفسها والسفاره القطريه والسفارات دول
اخرى هل يمكن ان يصدق انسان ان يكون هناك
تعليمات واوامر من جهات عليا من قوات
الدعم السريع
بالهجوم على هذه السفارات بالتاكيد هذا
يعني ان هناك مشكله في حلقه القياده بين
الذين هم يعملون السلاح على الارض وما
يمكن ان يفعلونه بمحض اختيارهم وبين
التعليمات التي تاتي من اعلى الان منحت
هذه الفرصه 48 ساعه لوصول التعليمات من
القيادات العليا الى القوات الادنى لكن هل
صحيح حلقه القياده اصلا لديها قدره على
السيطره حتى هناك ثالث غير معني بالتهدئه
على كل سنتابع التطورات من القاهره رئيس
تحرير صحيفه التيار السودانيه عثمان
مرجاني شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا القتال الدائر في الخرطوم ادى الى
انعدام الاكسجين والكهرباء بمستشفى الضعين
شرقي دارفور غربيه السودان وتشير
الاحصائيات الى وفاه 30 طفل حديثي الولاده
بالمستشفى وذلك منذ بدايه هذه الاحداث
وبمعدل اربعه اطفال كل يوم الامر الذي
اصبح مقلقا لاداره المستشفى خاصه بعد خروج
محطه توليد الكهرباء كهرباء المدينه عن
العمل متابع
تترقب امهات الاطفال بمستشفى الضعين شرقي
دارفور بخوف شديد لحظه انقطاع الكهرباء
فهي تعني نهايه الحياه للاطفال حديثيه
الولاده
المعارك بين الجيش والدعم السريع ادت الى
انعدام الاكسجين القادم من الخرطوم الامر
الذي صعب من عملياتهم هذه الاطفال ويسعى
في حياتهم الله معناتنا مع الكهرباء
والاكسجين صعبه لدرجه شديده حتى بتعدل
وفاه اطفال الليله الصباح يذوفه طفل بسبب
الاكسجين
والله لازعفناه بره في الاحياء حتى يلا
بعد
هنا في المستشفى بعد ثلاثه ولا اربعه
ساعات
اكثر من ثلاثين طفلا ماتوا حتى الان منذ
بدايه الاحداث ولا حلول تلوح في الافق مع
استمرار القتال وشح الوقود بالبلاد واقع
يعد الاكثر تعقيدا للقائمين على امر صحه
هنا خاصه قسم الاطفال ما عندنا نحن مولدات
بالنسبه للاكسجين وما عندنا الاكسجين في
اسطوانات فمن نعتمد على جهاز مولد بالنسبه
يعتمد على الكهرباء
فعدم توفر انقطاع التيار الكهربائي في
اليوم اكثر من 12 ساعه وما في مخزون وقود
كافي وين كان موجود برضو البابور بتاع
المستشفى المولد ما بيشتغل اكثر من اربعه
خمسه ساعات متواصله فبعض الاطفال بيكونوا
محتاجين لاكسجين متواصل فلما يحصل انقطاع
بالنسبه للتيار الكهربائي فالمولدات
بتاعته بتاعه الاكسجين الموجوده بتعتمد
الكهرباء كلها بتتوقف وبتسوق حاله الاطفال
فعندنا يعني كميه من الوفيات كانت الايام
اللي فاتت نتيجه للاكسجين
تخفيفا للمعاناه شكلت المبادره الشبابيه
بالضيعين غرفه للطوارئ تهدف الى المساهمه
في تحسين الاوضاع الانسانيه
بالشراكه مع السلطات الصحيه بالتركيز على
الاطفال بالمستشفى فازلين جهود كبيره
للتواصل مع المنظمات العامه في مجالات
الصحيه لتوفير يعني الادويه للاطفال وخاصه
فيما يتعلق بالاكسجين ايضا عندنا اتجاهين
نقدم يعني خدمه فيما يتعلق بالعمل الطاري
بالتعاون مع الجهات ذات الاختصاص وتتصدر
شرقيو دارفورد بحسب منظمه الصحه العالميه
ولايات السودان في قضيه وفاه الاطفال
حديثي الولاده يعود ذلك لعوامل عديده من
ضمنها عدم وجود عنبر خاص للاطفال الصغار
القتال الدائر في السودان حتى الان ادى
الى وفاته عشرات الاطفال ومن لم يمر
بالرصاص ماذا بنقص الاكسجين وانقطاع
الكهرباء
يسجل في السعوديه والعالم اليوم حدث
تاريخي يشهد انطلاق اول رائد فضاء سعوديه
عربيه هي ريانه برناوي وكذلك علي القرني
الذي يعد ايضا اول رائد فضاء سعودي يصل
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه الهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء اكدت جاهزيه صاروخ فالكون تسعه
ومركبه دراغون على منصه الاطلاق في
فلوريدا استعدادا طبعا لنقل طاقم مهمه اي
اكس 2 والتي تضم رائدي الفضاء السعوديين
ذكرت الهيئه ان هذه الرحله تاتي ضمن
برنامج السعوديه لرواد الفضاء الذي تم
اطلاقه في سبتمبر من العام 2020
وتتضمن اجراء اربعه عشره تجربه بحثيه
علميه رائده في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى كما
تعزز نتائج الابحاث ستعزز نتائج الابحاث
مكانه المملكه عالميا في مجال استكشاف
الفضاء وخدمه البشريه وتؤكد دور مراكز
الابحاث السعوديه في احداثي تاثير في عدد
من المجالات كالصحه للاستدامه وايضا تقنيه
الفضاء تضع هذه الرحله تضع السعوديه كاحدى
الدول القليله في العالم التي تتمكن من
ارسال رائدى من الجنسيه نفسها على متن
محطه الفضاء الدوليه وفي الوقت نفسه اتمنى
مؤخرا اجمال التدريبات المتعلقه بالرحله
وكانت بشكل عام التدريب على المهام
اليوميه التشغيليه لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
تدربنا على مركزين الابحاث الاوروبي
والياباني كذلك
التدريبات وجمله على كيفيه التعايش داخل
المحطه الفضاء الدوليه وكذلك محاكاه
للانطلاق والعوده التدرب على الادوات اللي
نستخدمها ان شاء الله في الابحاث العلميه
والابحاث
العمليه ان شاء الله على متر المحطه
فهذه التدريبات بشكل عام تثبت او او
تمكننا من القدره على النجاح في هذه
المهمه وكذلك بعد المهمه ان شاء الله نعود
الى ارض الوطن محققين جميع الاهداف
المرجوه من هذه الرحله
اكيد استاذ اصلا مهمتنا بالاساس هي مهمه
علميه فباذن الله سنقوم باجراء 14 تجربه
علميه بحثيه رائده يعني لاول مره في
التاريخ باذن الله هذه التجارب تعنى
بمجالات متعدده اولها هي ثلاث تجارب
توعويه تعليميه ستكون
لها علاقه بالتعاون مع الطلاب فهذه
التجارب كلها هدفها تحفيز الطلاب وتحفيز
الفضول لديهم في مجال الفضاء وباذن الله
سنقوم باجراء اربع تجارب علميه لها علاقه
بالخلايا المناعيه وهذه باذن الله حتكون
اول مره في التاريخ سنقوم بزراعه خلايا
مناعيه في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى بحيث انه
نزرع الخلايا ونضيف علاجات مختلفه عليها
ونشوف مدى استجابتها في بيئه الجاذبيه
الصوره وهذه البحث لاول مره يجرى في
التاريخ بدعم سمو سيدي حفظه الله
مع الرحله المنتظره لرواد الفضاء
السعوديين تشهد ثلاث مدن في المملكه اقامه
معارض السعوديه نحو الفضاء وذلك بالتزامن
طبعا مع انطلاق المهمه العلميه هذه
المعارض تقام في مدن الرياض ايضا جده
والظهران خلال الفتره من 21 من مايو
الجاري حتى الفاتح من يونيو المقبل
المعارض تهدف لي تقديم فرص فريده لاستكشاف
قطاع الفضاء وايضا التعرف على الرحلات
الفضائيه على تاريخها رفع مستوى الاهتمام
بالفضاء وعلومه وتخصصاته العلميه والتقنيه
لدى الاجيال الناشئه على كل للمزيد معنا
من الرياض مراسل العربيه نصفيان اهلا بك
هاني حدثنا اكثر عن هذه المعارض من حيث
انت
نعم ميسون ايضا هذا المعرض تحديدا والذي
نتواجد فيه في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
وهو واحد من المعرض الثلاثه التي ذكرتها
قبل قليل يعرض ايضا القطع التي سوف
يستخدمها ريانه وعلي وكذلك يعرض نموذج
لصاروخ فالكون وكذلك دراغون وايضا يعرض
ايضا وثائقيات وكذلك عن تاريخ الفضاء
وايضا مسارح علميه للاطفال من اجل تعريفهم
بالفضاء عموما ايضا في بدايه الخبر تحدثتي
عن البحوث العلميه وبما اننا نتحدث اليوم
عن 14 بحثا علميا مختلفا ومتعددا في
مجالات عده سوف يكون معي ضيفي المهندس
ماجد المشاري وهو مستشار في الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء نتحدث اليوم مرحبا بك
مهندس مشاري ونتحدث عن 14 او 14 بحثا
علميا سوف ينفذها ريانه وعلي دعنا نتحدث
عن 14 البحث علمي كيف سوف يتم تجربتها هل
تم او سبق وان تم تجربتها في احد
المختبرات في السعوديه من الذي هل هذه
تجربات او البحوث العلميه تم انشاؤه هنا
في السعوديه او تم ايضا استقطابها من دول
اخرى اولا اشكركم على الاستضافه والحقيقه
الرحله لكل من كلنا ننتظرها الليله هي
رحله علميه
بامتياز سيكون فيها رائده الفضاء ريان او
رعد الفضاء علي القرني باجراء 14 تجربه
علميه
السته من التجارب هذه لها علاقه بالمخ
والاعصاب وتهدف الى
قياس اثر السفر الى الفضاء والعيش في
الفضاء على
الوظائف الحيويه لجسم الانسان
سيتم قياس النشاط الكهربائي للدماغ سيتم
قياس التغير في طول العصب البصري قياس
تدفق الدم الى الدماغ وايضا قياس الضغط
الى الجمجمه باستخدام ادوات
متقدمه وتهدف هذه
التجارب الى قياس الوظائف الحيويه جسم
الانسان ومقارنتها بوجود الانسان على على
سطح الارض الهدف من هذه تجارب هو تطوير
وسائل
سفر امنه للانسان الى الفضاء ليذهب ويبقى
لمده طويله
مثل الذهاب الى القمر
والذهاب الى المريخ جيد يعني هناك نيه
مستقبل او تطمح اليه السعوديه بان يكون
هناك رحلات الى الفضاء وهناك ايضا من خلال
بحوثكم علميه التي يقومون بتجربتها طيب
ماذا عن البحوث الاخرى يعني كنا نتحدث عن
عمليات الاست نعم وايضا يعني تحدثنا ايضا
ان هناك جامعات سعوديه تشارك بشكل مباشر
مع ريان نعم يمكن انا ما ذكرت انه مستشفى
الملك فيصل التخصصي ومركز الابحاث وواحد
الجهات الرائده والمشاركه بدرجه كبيره في
في هذه الرحله ريان بن ناوي احد المنتسبين
الى هذا الصرح يعني ايضا من التجارب اربع
تجارب راح تدرس
تفاعل الخلايا المناعيه مع مع الالتهابات
وتهدف الى تطوير علاجات مبتكره
ممكن انها تساهم لذوي الالتهابات المزمنه
ايضا عندنا تجربه تجرى لاول مره بالفضاء
قامت بها جامعه الملك فهد بترول المعادن
فريق من الباحثين المتميزين وهي تهدف الى
تعزيز تقنيات الاستمطار هدف في هم المملكه
بدرجه كبيره شكرا لك مستشار
السعوديه للفضاء المهندس ماجد المشاري اذا
ميسون والساده المشاهدين لدينا ست ساعات
او تبقى ست ساعات واثنين وخمسين دقيقه
والثواني ما زالت تجري وهو موعد انطلاق
ريانه وعلي نحو الفضاء
والتحام ايضا
بالمحطه الدوليه للفضاء ولدينا ايضا في
الصوره الاخرى وبشكل سريع نماذج للصواريخ
السابقه التي تعرض في هنا في هذا المعرض
والتي تم تجربتها في السابق ولدينا من
الخلف النموذج صاروخ فالكون والذي سوف
يصعد عليه ريانه علي نحو المحطه الدولية
وسننتظر في العربيه ونتابع التطورات لحظه
بلحظه من الرياض مراسل العربيه نصفيان
شكرا جزيلا
فاصل ونواصل الخامسه مشاهدينا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه دانه كل من
السعوديه والامارات ومصر والاردن اقتحام
وزير الامن القوميه الاسرائيلي للمسجد
الاقصى في القدس الخارجيه السعوديه في
بيان لها اكدت ان القوات الاسرائيليه
مسؤوله عن تداعيات استمرار التجاوز على
المسجد الاقصى ودانت عمليه الاقتحام
الامارات دعت تل ابيب لوقف التصعيد ومنع
رفع التوتر في المنطقه الامين العام لمجلس
التعاون الخليجي جاسم البداوي شدد على
ضروره وقف الانتهاكات وحمل اسرائيل
مسؤوليه اي ردود فعل ناجمه عنها اما
الخارجيه المصريه فقد وصفت الاقتحام
بالتصرف الاستفزازي وهو عكس ما يجب ان
يتحلى به المسؤولون الرسميون بحسب التصريح
المصري
اتهمه محامي مالك موقع تويتر ايلون ماسك
اتهم شركه مايكروسوفت في رساله باساءه
استخدام بيانات الخدمه طلب بالتدقيق من
قبل شركه البرمجيات العملاقه نتابع
[موسيقى]
مواجهه وشيكا ساحتها رقميه واسلحتها
خوارزميات هائله تلك هي الحروب العصريه
التي يصبح اغلى ما فيها المعلومات المشفره
انها المعركه القادمه بين عصفور ازرق يدعى
تويتر وشركه البرمجيه العملاقه مايكروسوفت
فتيلها اشتعل منذ ان غرد الملياردير
الامريكي ايلون ماسك قائلا انهم يستخدمون
بيانات تويتر بشكل غير قانوني وحان وقت
رفع الدعوه القضائيه وفي رساله تحذيريه
حملت ادعاءات غامضه وجهها الاكسسبيرو
محامي ملك تويتر الى الساتيا ناديلا
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه مايكروسوفت تتمحور
حول تجاوز حجم الطلب المعقول لبيانات
تويتر بل حتى استخدامها بافراط واساءه
مضيفا ان الاتفاقيه التي عقدت بينهما
لتشرع هذا الكم الهائل من الاستخدام علما
بانهم استرجعوا اكثر من 26 مليار تغريده
في عام 2022 وحده هذا عدا عن ان الاتفاقيه
بينهما نصت على انه لا يحق لميكروسوفت
استرداد ايا من بيانات تويتر لاي كيان او
وكاله دون اخبارهم مطالبا بالتدقيق المفصل
والممل للبيانات التي اخذتها من تويتر او
دمرتها ولاي تطبيق قدمتها ولماذا في
المقابل اكتفى المتحدث باسم مايكروسوفت
فرانكشو بان الشركه ستاخذ بالاعتبار اسئله
وطلبات تويتر
وسترد عليها بالشكل المناسب مؤكدا انهم
يتطلعون الى شراكه طويله الامد اسراء
الصغير العربيه
الخامس انتهت شكرا للمتابعه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات